hello and big congratulations on the
movie first off
um so after you did your cameo
in train wreck did you know right then
and there
that judd wanted to bring you back for a
bigger role in a future movie
no i was just hoping i did a
good job for him in that movie and uh
that was actually almost more stressful
that one day was probably
harder than the whole movie because i
wasn't used to his
method at that point and i didn't know
him as well
and um you know first days are always
scary but it was my first
day and my last day was my only day so
but so doing this film
was actually oddly easier than that one
day
so given that thought uh what advice
would you give to another actor who's
about to work
with judd for the very first time just
to make the most of his process
hmm i think um what advice i guess i
would just like
lay out how he how he works and
and tell them to trust the process that
it really does
it gets very enjoyable once you get over
the hump of
a new a new way of working that it gets
really really really fun
is it the improv that makes his style so
different because i know you've done
some improv like cyrus comes to mind
before what what made this experience so
drastically different
um yes a lot the improv aspect but also
with other people who are professional
stand-up comedians
but yes well jonah and john are
i mean they they do i don't know if they
actually do stand up or not
but they are at that level um but these
are people
you know in the trenches day in day out
you know going up and performing at the
club like we would
shoot and then they would go to blow off
some steam and like
go and go and work a comedy club
uh so that level of people that
you know are that smart and funny
and fast uh was really thrilling to be
around
well for what it's worth you go
toe-to-toe with them from start to
finish
this one i loved i love the performance
here i also wanted to ask you about this
because
it kind of it doesn't feel like as much
of a thing to me
anymore but there is that that kind of
trope that once you play a mother
a certain part of your career is over so
as someone who has made the absolute
most of those opportunities was that
ever a concern
for you and is there anything that
you're getting out of these characters
that maybe came as a pleasant surprise
to you
uh that's a great question actually no i
really regret starting down this road
and i really regret starting to do that
i
i
was you know talked into it and i was
also not this but i mean just that
that change um and
i really always felt like i could play a
lot of things honestly it's harder
it's probably more of a stretch than
other things um
but uh it's it's uh
yeah it's uh i guess i said it all
i'm surprised to hear you say that
especially because i think you've made
such a big impression in those roles
over the years yeah but you're still
saying those roles you know
that's not really i i don't want to do
that i have you know i think every actor
and actress has a lot of
um dimensions to them and
uh to you know if if the scope of what
uh is being written and being made
is narrow and you want to keep working
you make
you know you do what you can i mean i do
i i tried
it it wasn't maybe not the right road
but
you know i do try to make the most of it
that is that's a fair point and just to
follow up on that i mean
you've done such a wide variety of work
over the years since the very beginning
is there any sort of i guess like an
itch that you haven't scratched that yet
that you're dying to try out
uh well sure i mean i mean even
genres that i would love to to be in you
know
the femme fatale and in a noir and in
um i mean i still think there are other
aspects of
even romantic comedies i really love
them but you know really at a screwball
level
uh there's there's so many
many the breadth of of as much as women
are there there's
there's all so many roles um
but uh yeah i mean sometimes when it's
like
the heart of the movie you know you hear
that a lot it can kind of sometimes
mean like thanks a lot we won't pay you
for for what it's worth i i really do
mean what i said you've
made the role so much more than i ever
could have expected in here
i love this movie and i'm really happy
to be in this and
it's actually very unusual for um
i mean it's basically the key
relationship the father
his father is really the key
relationship when he's he's not present
and but it and he hovers over the whole
film and that it's this father and son
have to work
he has to work this out this this inner
feelings about his dad um but
it's really the mom and the son who are
left with each other and
judd gives a lot of real estate to to
that relationship
and to uh the nuance of
um you know that dynamic in a family
which is supe very very very unusual to
yeah
to have this kind of part be a central
part
that's what makes this really different
yep and you you absolutely made the most
of it congratulations on this and who
knows maybe we can get a full feature
for the dog walker at some point
i would watch it for what it's worth
including the ponytails
thank you so much congratulations